many of you know  i've been critical of joe biden i don't  care about the democratic party  but joe biden has just seen one of the  most incredible 180s of any presidency  in the direction of good over the last  three months that i have ever seen  blockbuster jobs report from july  gas prices down inflation down  out of afghanistan got ayman al-zawahiri  i understand afghanistan was not in the  last two months but it's all cumulative  now  um inflation reduction act pact act the  infrastructure bill from last year  and now student loan forgiveness  this is  increasingly an extraordinary presidency  and i am shocked that i am even saying  it myself